- Could diversity take away
from your creativity as well?
- I think the critical thing is,
stay true to your idea,
stay true to your mission,
your purpose, that's fundamental,
that's your foundation.
But, within that, then the next questions,
how do you reach your audience?
And then also, how do you do it?
How do you get a market, how
do you create the product?
I think by including
diversity you actually
increase the level of
creativity dramatically.
And the financial results of companies
that are strong and diverse
tend to be way better
than those that are very
restrictive and traditional.
Now I think, why does
it increase diversity?
Again, at Spotify it's really cool,
they have this music
room and then they have
this area where they can watch people
on focus groups and stuff like that.
And they deliberately
will get very diverse
people listening to their new products.
And actually going through
the whole usability
of their new products.
I guess I've lived in
technology a long time,
you cannot believe how great
engineers don't realize
how difficult to use their products are.
And they might have
built the best mouse trap
in the world, they might have built
the best features of functions with
the coolest kinds of music
download in the world,
but unless it's usable
and simple and intuitive,
then it's not going to get the air time.
So you never ever ever get disappointed
by getting user feedback in
terms of (mumbles) products.
And I think around that you
don't just want to (mumbles)
unless you've got a very narrow product,
just to one segment of society.
It's much better if you really
want to scale your product
to do that and then go
out to other segments
and be very diverse in your thinking.
I think the creativity, just
speaking from me personally,
by having a lot of
people within the company
challenge me, from very
diverse backgrounds,
gives me a much greater
appreciation of how to do
the best for our customers.
And again it's so true in life.
Sometimes I think as an entrepreneur,
you get a bit successful, you
stop believing your own PR
and you get a bit comfortable.
And when you do that, you
kind of lose your creativity.
Whereas, what your
questions all about Kirk,
is about how do you
accelerate that creativity.
Now I think diversity
is just one of the ways
you could do that and
get some fantastic input.
Really strong invention in a (mumbles).
And then as a leader, you kind
of got to make the choices
and start executing them,
delivering on that vision.
- Yeah I'm definitely
with Steven on this one.
I don't know that we really disagree a lot
on the questions anyway,
just different sides
of the coin on most of these.
I don't see a world in
which for any company,
adding diversity would
take away from creativity.
Just I don't know how that happens.
I think maybe your own,
if you're injecting other
people into a company then
maybe the responsibility
on you isn't as great to be creative.
If you have to come up with everything,
then now that you have people,
you can rely on maybe
you don't have to come up
with as many ideas, maybe
your own personal creativity.
I don't know if that's
what he's getting at.
But look at what's in the
best interest of your company.
The best ideas win.
If it's only you coming up with ideas
and the ideas are just
okay, by adding more people
into the mix, they can take
that okay idea into a great one.
And so, if that means
you're not coming up with
every single idea for the business,
then maybe that's a good thing to help you
get to where you need to go.